hey guys so this is a bit of an update
video not a full ColdFusion video as you
can probably remember and the last
couple of days are at least a video
about the airlander 10 which is the
world's largest aircraft and as it turns
out the thing actually just crashed 24
hours after I made the video the crash
occurred during its second ever test
flight so it is kind of a strange turn
of events here looking at the footage
it's not a crash in how you would expect
it but more of a slow-motion train wreck
hybrid aerial vehicles which makes the
aircraft isn't releasing any official
statements just yet but they are saying
both the pilots and the ground crew are
safe despite this they're planning to
push ahead with the developments of the
aircraft the company was actually hoping
to build 10 of these per year by the
year 2021 so we have to wait and see if
it was pilot error or an actual
mechanical failure but either way it's
not looking the greatest for the project
maybe they should rename it the air
crash attend anyways that was just a
quick update as a side point I was
seeing a lot of comments of people
talking about how much helium this craft
uses and the fact that helium in its
usable form is quite rare and that we
may even begin to run out of it in
coming decades and you guys have a point
helium is used for a lot of things from
equipment in the medical field to
scientific experiments and engineering
applications the gas is extremely hard
to extract from the air so usually has
to be extracted from the Earth's crust
so the question is even though a huge
deposit of helium was found in Tanzania
enough to fill 1.2 million MRI scanners
should we be using helium for such
applications such as the airlander 10
anyway while I'm here I might as well
just tell you what's coming up I do have
a video planned on the biggest mistakes
made by some of the biggest companies
and I think you guys will love that
video it's full of irony and a whole
bunch of face palming and after that I
still am working on how big is Amazon so
hopefully I'll have that out in the next
couple of weeks and there's some other
good stuff to look forward to so anyway
I want to keep you guys for any longer
thanks for watching and enjoy the rest
of your day cheers guys have a good one